[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
and it's like a rag indian yeah india
india is asian yeah yeah indian is asian
arab guy oh yeah i'm confused so is it
is he from the middle east or is he
indian or is he asian he came over he's
arab he came over from uh
middle east middle east and he worked
himself to the top and you know they
just saved their money
and then he mean they saved their money
yeah what do you mean
you act like all people from the middle
east are good with money
well they don't go you're gonna
you know how you hear something you're
like i don't even participate
that's where i was at and i was trying
to clean it up and then he said
asian then he said arab and then he said
dubai
all kinds of [ __ ] all kind of racist
[ __ ] came out all in one it's like my
stepdad
from west virginia trying not to be
racist yeah
they have the towel you know their hair
is always dry
[Applause]
you know the lamp yeah
like they're pulling it out of you as
well like they're trying to pull the
racists out of you yeah
you know come on follow me follow me you
know well his wish was known 7-eleven
and he made it happen
he did what was that he worked it at
7-eleven right to richard's story night
owes
and not only does he own it he has uh
money enough to
have family come over and give them jobs
so it's just like a whole business
okay okay all right i know what you're
trying to say go ahead break it please
he worked at 7-eleven started off at
7-eleven and then he eventually worked
his way up to
build enough capital to buy ship yeah
and own it
yeah right now the brand or he just
has a franchise of him no he owns the
whole setting because i could open a
7-eleven right now
yeah anyone can open a 7-eleven i could
open a starbucks mcdonald's
franchise yeah so is he mystery can we
look this up chin is he mr 7-eleven
this is the guy he's the guy yeah cause
he's talking about you were talking
about coffee
coffee beans yeah the filipinos on it so
yeah this is like right i love
that but not the filipinos yeah you may
sound like the country invested
we'll take coffee yeah this is for the
it's people it's like the green bay
packers like everyone owns the team
the great package the filipinos
they're just cheeseheads you say look
japanese retailers seven and eyeholes
which owns convenience store chain 711
has agreed to buy the smoothie chain gas
stations from methamphetamine petroleum
21 billion
well they're they're japanese they're
japanese malik
nah that's not true yeah yeah they're
yeah malik
nah that's not true there's a hold on i
don't want to get mad but you know
there's a big difference between
japanese
yes yeah and dubai
right you know that right you do know
that
and here's the thing here's the thing
that hurts your argument it's not like
this happened last year they've owned it
since 1991
yeah you made it sound like breaking
news
like there was ticket tape going down
the bottom of the screen like this like
did you guys hear about 7-eleven middle
eastern guy
garitches oh here's what happened dude
dude probably worked he was a clerk
there saved up
and got enough uh cash to buy his own
friend but he doesn't own all 7-elevens
he probably has like two of them where
the hell did you get this story i
i uh arab told me that arab yeah
and and arab or just arab in general
a lot of people on the street and it
sounds like they're lying
i don't think you ever know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
i think you read the middle of the book
and say i know the story
so joe since you were talking about
coffee bean and food
you're gonna love this one do you like
24 7 uh
stores check out
check this out i know this one japanese
guy that lives in dubai
just starting from the bottom yeah
he's like like like coffee bean man it's
like those are probably some rich
filipinos
yeah yeah yeah yeah right family money
yeah
are you gonna have this elaborate story
about it yeah it's you know it came from
the philippines yeah he
he [ __ ] up all the sayings like rag
search he started with a mop
now he owns
what is that sharply at the top now he
owns
yes and now he has a family you know
what i mean
well he has a family all right my badge
rags to riches
let's pitch that great that's a great tv
show bro i got a lot of creative ideas
just listen to me hey
hey i got an idea yeah uh reddit would
you go to pitch
anything do not bring him in the room
will not
sell the goddamn show there might not
sell like we like
it can you get rid of him get rid of him
can you get rid of rags to riches
look we haven't written this script yet
but we want it right
we want to write his character at it
what
we haven't used a pitch we don't we
don't we already know whatever you do
yeah get him out get this one out get
ready
you threw it out there sometimes bro you
just how'd you throw
it out there
7-eleven though has this is what trips
me out about 7-eleven
is um one they don't need gas for people
to come in usually the draw
is gas for people to come into the store
uh-huh not not 7-eleven they can give a
[ __ ] anymore
they don't even slurpee [ __ ] they
anywhere people go in and now it's to
the fact
they're not even using name brand foods
anymore they got
seven eleven shoes now they have their
pizza they got their pizza they got
their
chips burritos i bought their ruffle
7-elevens
it's like the knockouts ruffles i bought
it yeah was it good a little cheaper
it's like ruffles
exact same they're they're whatever you
know what's weird to me
is when a wheat like when we're on the
road we stop at semolin for water
[ __ ] whatever yeah and people are in
there and they're buying the chicken
wings i'm like oh man
i don't know if i would eat those i
don't know what about the hot dogs i
wouldn't eat those 700 hot dogs
but i don't like hot dogs yeah but if
you like them 7-eleven is pretty legit
hot dog
oh there you are yeah okay i'll go for
that yeah remember the big goal the big
gold
[ __ ] is still around
god damn it what do you think this is a
where are they now
vh1 documentary you remember
everyone was drinking this much and then
this much came up and then when they had
that big goat man those were the days
there was a clown selling hamburgers
ronald mcdonald
delicious and the credits rolled up
that's my movie y'all ever had a big
goal
so funny you guys remember the ipod
music on it lots of music on a metal
square oh my god
i have more of these stories i have more
of these choices
did you say ipod you know an arab guy
rag richard
create the ipod yeah with steve jobs
no that's a difference malik is the
worst time
traveler like he's from the year 2090
and he's and he's in he's in our current
time but he still thinks he's talking to
people in 2090.
there are these two towers in new york
and people work there everyone's all
what
but it's facts all wrong he's like these
two japanese man
they flew the planes into the [ __ ]
building
it was their first day and they ain't go
too great
you're great i think you guys should
know the buildings are empty how about
that
now you're great you're a joy i love you
john
i had malik actually walk me in with an
umbrella oh my god oh
remember when diddy used to have that
guy that yeah i was his father
when he was dressed
he was like dancing yeah but he was a
real good dancer oh he was a great
dancer but
he was his straight up personal
assistant right and then he like
branched off on his own yeah
like his own like tv show he was the he
he was the host of
jesus jesus
he was great yeah yeah i want smoothies
i want one
he's like i'm glad you brought this up
imagine not like walking around with an
umbrella over my head going
hey you remember when coca-cola used to
be a soda
that's it and then that's it it just
leaves you put up with that
all day well joe you know you remember
when
they had this play station you remember
amc theaters
they had this thing called popcorn
continue continue mr
do you remember how big did he was back
in the day when he was all up on mtv
yeah remember making the band was great
my favorite episode is when he said go
walk to cheese cheese
to new york to get cheesecake i'll walk
to brooklyn brother
yeah you get a certain kind of
cheesecake and he goes and walks back at
midnight
so you better hurry the [ __ ] up yeah
this is [ __ ] up yeah
yeah and then he was secretly recording
them he's like it's [ __ ] up
all i'm doing is actually give me a
slice of cheesecake and i give you a
contract yeah remember that
i loved it he was an [ __ ] he was no
he wasn't right he was kidding he was
pretty funny
all right all right well let me break
down let me break down diddy because i'm
a huge ditty fan
uh so the kid when he was a kid he was
at he was going to college
yeah and he met heavy d okay heavy d was
performing you know they bring
entertainment to the colleges he met
heavy d sold him on some [ __ ] you
know i mean whatever it was that he said
i can do this i can do that for you
heavy gave him a number gave him the
address of uptown records
andre harrell and he goes yo you have in
new york
show up i got you the [ __ ]
showed up and he continued to show up
every week
he would catch the train from his
college all the way to new york
and then catch the train back and go to
college did he go to morehouse
i think it was he went from morehouse to
new york hang out with heavy
and then go back and literally no sleep
every weekend he would do that and then
go to college then he met uh then he met
andre harrell
got in as an intern as an intern worked
for see this
video rags to riches worked for free
work for free
right as uh you know marketing street
team right and charge a street team
promoting new albums coming up
and then he looked on the shelf and he
saw jodeci
and mary j blige was still on this on
the shelf
and he goes and he listened to when he
went to andre he goes yo
these two right here about to blow up
and andre was like i don't know what to
do with them because everyone was
wearing suits and ties back then you
know that's what groups look like yeah
and then diddy's the one that came up
with that image for them
and he said just give me a shot let me
blow them up and
andre was like go for it if you can do
it you'll be in charge of the whole
goddamn company
next thing you know he blew him up took
over uptown i didn't know that then
started bad boys
no he got fired from uptown oh wow
because he was being cocky
like any 20 year old would be right with
success
yeah yeah yeah andre and mary j blige
and jodi
yes and then andre uh fired him and then
uh he was broke for a few months
and then he created uh bad boys bad boy
he discovered craig mack and b and then
he
took that risk with biggie yeah who
wanted to touch biggie at that time you
know what i mean like how do you market
that
big fat guy yeah [ __ ] killed it
yeah and then he uh hired the murderer
of
tupac great crazy story okay well that
that's not how we wanted
it i hate that i guess
then he gave the murder weapon to jayla
but i want to say that
i didn't want to [ __ ] play that part
let's stick to the rags to riches
hey remember when him and jayla were
dating and then i guess
jayla was like oh this is cool like
diddy's dope and then they get in the
limo and he's like hey here's the gun
she's like what
what [ __ ] yeah hold on i just wanted
hennessy
yeah she's like what was this someone
got shot at the club
yeah there was just a [ __ ] look first of
all we're this we don't have any proof
or evidence of this yeah sure
all of this we don't want to know yeah
it's allegedly you can't say that
it's kind of from the street it's street
talk kind of but also jayla was like
yeah that's exactly what happened did
she say that
pretty sure nope can't say that either
man
that's enough to get sued by man hey
pretty sure she said uh
diddy shot everybody we'll be right back
after this
i don't want her coming after me but he
did get arrested on weapon charges
yeah he did but i mean [ __ ] man what up
cheyenne went to prison
what i'm saying is what i'm saying is
get that [ __ ] cheesecake yeah do
whatever it is do whatever the [ __ ] it
takes
walk to get that [ __ ] cheesecake but
you're working with diddy
who won who won that scene you know what
i'm saying like i don't know i remember
it doesn't matter hey man no one won
that season
guess what all of those guys are making
cheesecake
although they're not walking to get
cheesecakes they work at the cheesecake
factory hey my name is chapa how can i
help you guys
close water bread i can bring extra
bread
remember it now it's whatever i think he
sold it remember the sean john the whole
club
yeah brilliant he blew that up the
velour jumpsuits
i had the floor he had the the raised uh
embroidered uh
stitching on the chest
everything it got bad he sold it what
are you sure he did it was a tv network
called revolt tv
and that was his that's it that's his
did he sell that no he still owns it he
still owns it
he wants to rock though doesn't he yeah
that's what put him over the top that's
the rock that's what put him over the
top that's the big boy that's the one
that made him
a billionaire i used to drink that [ __ ]
all the time too yeah well that's why
he's a billionaire
makes it you and a lot of other people i
know right
what was your flavor what was your
flavor peach just a regular one
that was peach too really just right
just regular the blue
bottle are you you're not a big drinker
no my feet swell now
oh you're my feet swell not good yeah
from alcohol a [ __ ] a damn it sucks
i'll drink you know
i love i love jamison right on the rocks
and then my feet uh really love jameson
it they on to it it goes straight to my
feet damn you get hurt
yeah it's just i get that on planes i
have to take my shoes off yeah man
yeah that's what it is hey bro hey it's
funny huh no no
buddy huh
[Laughter]
hi guys my name is malik you guys want
some extra red
that's right oh my god you're funny joe
yes thank you for letting me open for
you though oh dude dude
man your show be lady boy yeah man he
was never seen anything like
but what
i said take notes from i did when i
opened for you i'm like take
notes man because it's a different game
than you know our typical
crew that obviously broke up now but the
typical crew we're all kind of similar
but
when i went to yours and you see the
merch and the performance and the dj
and just just the good vibes in the back
and like how
your you know your sister's there and
it's just like this well-oiled machine
and like
yeah it's such like a spectacle yeah you
wrote like you're like uh it's
the only person i've seen come close to
it would be kevin hart oh thank you
there's that similar vibe thank you and
you got to get to a certain level to do
that you know
i'm not saying that like flappers
[ __ ] get a dj and you know i know
right now
buzzy's cafe get your cheesecake in the
bag
that would be back there
and it's crazy it's very interesting
because like you know i know like yeah
you do a lot of arenas so it was like
you know to see you back in a club
environment
you know people just get like they're
just so up close and they just like love
you so much
yeah they just want to talk to you like
while you're up there yeah man you know
it's like
and you ha but you handle that like yeah
so well
thank you you know what i mean you
handle it really dude
you're you're in san marcos with me
which is a venue that has never had
comedy before so
yeah i was they'll man i really i've
never had it where it's like a
bunch of people being chatty one or two
i can light them up i like to roast it
that's fun
but when it was the entire like your
time out
it was like overwhelming i didn't really
know what to do i called first i'm like
dude you ever dealt with this
and he's the first guy i hit up oh
that's dope yeah perfect dude
thank you man yeah you told me you're
like what the heck [ __ ] you
in there was like show a little respect
for yourself
yeah never text somebody with a problem
and it starts off off like this
hey joe crowl is a little rowdy i was in
a high school auditorium
high school no [ __ ] man
high school [ __ ] accordion bleachers
coming out the sides of the wall
are you guys ready who's waiting for
some comedy tonight
we got brendan's job
it's going to be this guy did stand up
at a rave
and he's like you know [ __ ] trying like
yeah
yeah that's a pure [ __ ] show i had i had
a good time
yeah yeah no but you you got to do stuff
like that yeah
that's it for him you should do that i
did them i had those
i did all kinds of [ __ ] i did uh was
your worst gig
well i had one gig that paid so much
money but it was i knew going
into it was going to be a [ __ ] show was
uh the o2
festival it was like morrissey jay-z
yeah were the headliners on that weekend
and i was in the comedy tent
do you know what the [ __ ] that is no i
don't that's a tent in the middle of the
festival
where people go to sleep oh no because
the show's going on so long
so they just want to lay down so there's
this big tent in the middle
and i have to go up and tell and you
you're hearing everything
because it's just a tent yeah and
literally people are just sleeping
on the ground and i got to go up and do
30. was this in london and at the end
well at the end of my set i went like
this
ladies and gentlemen enjoy pablo
francisco
i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here before
mary j blige comes up
did he coming where's the cheesecake
someone said cheesecake someone eats
cheesecake wrong way again
you gotta step over here so you had to
do 30 minutes 30 minutes but it paid
well
i paid so good bro yeah so good
but sometimes you gotta go through those
tough ones yeah but also sometimes you
know like it's gonna be a [ __ ] show but
it pays well i'll say like all right
all right yeah i do what you want yeah
that was it overnight too i flew to
london i was there for like maybe 36
hours and flew right back
and i got on another plane didn't even
go home and then flew to like
missouri or something to do some shows
that's when i was just a road are you
back touring
now
they got me on a strict uh lockdown
oh because you're shooting a movie yeah
the movie oh yeah
so they don't want me to they don't want
me to socialize with anybody
have you guys started wait wait don't
you guys what is his hair
have you guys started shooting uh no we
start shooting i i go into
like lock lockdown two-week quarantine
in one room
uh april 11th i swear to god bro what
are you shooting now l.a
no we're shooting in canada oh [ __ ]
steven spielberg is a [ __ ] bro
he's he's amazing
yeah i'm gonna say i'll put it out there
and so is dan lynn from ride back
uh films dude these guys are
there there's a reason why these guys
are at the top of their game
just to be around it right it's just
amazing like this guy has
dude you're talking about saving private
ryan and
you know indiana jones and here he is
with joe coy's movie
like full on in that's so [ __ ] like
he's just like like
half ass you know like he's on board and
he's not he's not the director
he's just he's the studio but he's he's
he's financing it everything and and
literally he's
he's every step of the way man from
picking the director to pick in the
the actors and all that he's he's the
draft the script
everything he's he's he's right and he's
dialed in
yeah i don't think you get to his level
with you know not doing
being like that yeah like a type like
you know yeah
it's it's it's amazing like like we just
got a note from him uh
last week and i was just like like
literally when i when i got off the the
zoo meeting i just i was like
is this real like did this man really
make a note
and he needs to see it did you shop it
around or was it just a
steven spielberg uh no this is how it
went down dan lynn
dan lynn you know aladdin too with will
smith right yeah that's his and then it
won
it too that's his all the lego movies
those are his
and uh i pitched him easter sunday about
a year and a half ago we couldn't get a
writer attached to it right
so easter sunday is based on my life it
all happens on one day
and uh so that's the the pitch right and
then um but there's funny [ __ ] too as
well
yeah i didn't have malik in the room
i thought
so dan i pitched it to dan dan we were
trying to get a rider attached you know
you know a lot of uh conflicting uh
things were
you know we couldn't get someone
attached to it so anyways
i i shot coming in hot right so when i
shot coming in hot it
aired coming my second netflix special
and when it aired
spielberg watched it which is the
craziest thing right
and then we get a phone call like
immediately after he watched it
bring this kid in for a meeting right
when i don't know why he called me kid
um
pitched it again you know and he bought
it in the room so
him holly barrio everybody over at uh
amblin man
came on now and then and then one draft
can uh
ken chang uh well came up with the first
just one draft off of
you know the notes and the the things
that we pitched
and the first draft stephen was like
yeah let's shoot it like literally like
no no have you done movies before
i mean i've done like indie stuff but
nothing but nothing else
left this level like yeah man everything
i'm i'm
it's crazy like every every single
detail i'm on it you know what i mean
like you should be at your store yeah
it's like here's the cast like they're
showing me everybody's auditions and
and you know i'm going with the writers
and going over the uh well writer and
going over you know notes with that
and then me calling out my cameos who i
want and
yeah yeah we're going over i must miss
that call yes
what's cool about you man is like you're
so
focused but like you mean you like
looking at you and like talking to you
all the time like you're just you have
so much [ __ ] fun
oh thanks you know what i mean like that
that's what i like admire
about you well we'll soak soak it up
when you can because when this movie
drops i don't think he's coming back
here
you coming back you're not well
unfortunately yeah this is going to be
okay which one's my camera stevens
fan page email i did you know his cameo
his sister didn't reply back to me
my sister goes who's mali who's malik
then he asked if i needed cheesecake can
you tell them yes
[Laughter]
man that's funny you you do dope [ __ ]
it's cool to watch
thank you so you'll shoot this movie and
then you go
on tour you think this episode of
fighter and the kids with
joe coy my filipino brother
is brought to you by blue chew blue chew
is making waves and bringing more
confidence to the sack
that's right blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but
in chewable form at a fraction of the
cost blue chew tablets combat all forms
of ed and can help men gain
extra confidence when it's time to go
boys blue chew is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor
office no awkward conversations no wait
in line at the pharmacy
ships right to your crib in the discreet
little package all right
the process is super simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days best part it's
all
online man blue chews tablets are made
in the us of a
and ship direct so it's cheaper than the
pharmacy so
if this sounds like something you could
use in the bedroom little extra
confidence when it's time to go
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information
and i got a deal for you guys try blue
chew free when you use the promo code
fighter
at checkout just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluechew.com promo code
fighter to receive your first month free
and i thank bluechu for being part of
fighter in the kids
it's 2021. you guys know this and you
know what's popping right now it should
been popping for a long time
is your mental health that's right a lot
of people talking to their friends but
they're not helping you're talking your
family members they're not helping
why don't you get with a real licensed
professional therapist
who can help you achieve the happiness
whatever problem you're dealing
with your anxiety that can help with all
that better help is a customized
online therapy that offers video phone
even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see you see anyone on
camera if you don't want to but you can
we got you covered it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy
you can start communicating with your
therapist in under 48 hours
join the million of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about
see if it's for you because you are your
greatest asset all right
so if you could use a little help man
maybe get more clarity in your life
i'm telling you this is a great thing
this podcast fighting the kids is
sponsored by betterhelp
and you guys get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com
fighter that's better dot com slash
fighter
you do dope shot it's cool to watch
thank you
so you'll shoot this movie and then you
go on tour you think
yeah that's what i want to do because
the movie's gonna shoot how long two
months
it's gonna be two months yeah two months
vancouver
vancouver
yep yeah jay jay's my director man oh
i'm so excited
um i can never say his last name if you
want to look it up
uh super troopers you know he's done you
know he's a broken lizard
that's exactly what you said he's right
there in the middle end of jen there he
is
see i could never see his last i got it
i got it that's no [ __ ] dope okay
uh say his name i could never say it i
just call him jay the sucker yeah
chandra sandra sandra
genius but that whole cruise genius by
the way broken lizard is amazing
they're great talk about rags the riches
those guys they all lived in the same
frat house together they went to college
together they
became a comedy troupe on their own uh
raised their own money
and you know created that so funny oh
they're so funny and jay's just a genius
steve lemmy's a genius all those guys
are
are amazing so don't wear your belt like
that jay but yeah i hear you yeah
that's awesome that's like oh five yeah
that's whatever hey let him do it he's
drunk
he's allowed to do that he's so he's the
guy uh
yeah in super troopers where's where he
starts uh prostituting
like what what the [ __ ] are you doing
he's like hey boys
he's like 40 to for me to touch it seeks
to see me touch it
and he's like 80 for a cj there you go
once the zj goes
if you got ash can't afford it
i like what they get when they're both
uh locked into the uh the back of the
truck remember when they got locked in
they've been there for
hours yeah and then jay opens it up and
he goes it smells like sex in here
he's so funny man have you seen it
yeah it is a classic yeah i didn't see
part two though
i didn't either i love it love it
everybody did you see come in america
too
yes i did oh well it wasn't they've
heard awful things okay let's not do
that
let's not say that's it well no that's
why he's my hero man eddie's my hero
eddie's everybody's hair oh he killed it
but
yeah i'm sure he killed it i haven't
seen it i was
like i come to america for me the first
one it's cool
it's not like you know you didn't like
it no it's good oh but i i think it's
quiet
that's great it's great oh life is
amazing
yeah but uh it's tough to do a sequel in
2021
well it's also tough to do a sequel when
you're touching something as great
as coming that's what i'm saying like we
some things don't need a sequel yeah
like i'm thinking yeah that like on
breakfast club
uh i think it was yesterday i listened
to them every morning charlotte they had
charlemagne was like man i we got early
release on it he's like i don't want to
say anything he's like
it felt good because i looked seeing
like arsenio hall and the whole team
back together
but it was just a bad movie he did he
was like they wrote like
they they wrote it to be funny where
they should just wrote a good story but
yeah but not a good story
so then they had fans like calling in
like what's your opinion on
you know of the the new come to america
and out of whatever 50 college not
one was like oh it's fantastic like i
was too cheesy too
yeah it was awesome well i think what
happened
uh was they used the same formula from
the first movie
does that make sense yeah yeah so it's
pretty much it's kind of like uh
dumb and dumber oh yeah so when dumb and
dumber came out they were using
all of the same yeah that made the first
one so amazing but
but the time that the first one came out
it was yeah it was
but that's that'll hold up like those
still that still holds up like dumb and
dumb are definitely holding no dumb and
dumber does not matter i'm talking about
dumb and dumb
the new ones it's like but when they
wrote dumb and dumber it's like it's a
good
story yeah and those guys are so funny
you're gonna find the funny
in there yeah but now like dumb and
number er and then coming
to america it's like they were like oh
let's write funny instead of let's write
a good story for everybody to follow and
they had a formula yeah and they were
just
replacing yep dialogue within the
formula yeah yeah
i mean they're going to watch it oh you
should yeah you know it's the most
it's the most streamed movie of 2021 on
any streaming platform well
over over that jamie foxx one uh seoul
oh yeah oh damn yeah well i mean you
gotta think about how many generations
is eddie murphy
everyone [ __ ] with them did you hear
about do do you listen to mark maron at
all do you know mark oh i love mark
merritt yeah he's so he was on mark
maren's podcast
literally my favorite podcast he had
eddie on there and uh it was great
just recent yeah it came out like last
week and uh eddie and him talk for an
hour
and he was talking about doing stand-up
he's like i haven't done stand-up
forever since my delirious special
and he's like since raw since raw and
then he was like i had all this time off
he was one of the reasons
i came back he's like because i was
making shitty movie after shitty movie
after i was getting these razzy awards
and he's like and
people forgot like maybe they forgot i
wasn't funny so i was gonna do stand up
to show these [ __ ] like
oh no i'm still funny man he's like i
also took a break from movies because i
was just making bad movies
yeah he was like he was like they just
weren't bad they just weren't good so
i was gonna come back and make good
movies which come to america he might
hide again
yeah but dolomite was amazing oh yeah oh
yeah
but people hate on like i think all the
nutty professors are [ __ ] great
like brilliant all of them are great
that's the one nutty professor that he
he wishes like he was like he thought he
was going to win like
yeah awards for that because of him
playing all those characters doing the
whole
dinner table family everything yeah he
should have he should have went off
there
he goes that's the one he was like it
killed him
yeah yeah that should have killed him
yeah he's still
acting yeah like like there's never
gonna be an acting performance like that
ever again people try to do it when you
play all those characters yeah
so good job he stole that performance
like there's no way that can ever be
duplicated or top
i don't know if you knew this but so um
they didn't want him to do all those
characters
really so he had to audition he goes he
goes let me do it he goes what if i
audition as the characters wow he'll
come he's like i'll come in as
each character who's going to be better
and i'll audition all the characters and
he did it and they were like
okay yeah dude you should you should
hear him on mayor because marion's
talking about how he came up and stand
up oh
16. yeah i know i know his whole
background he was on the road like with
real like vet new york comics yep and
mark's like damn it
16 he's like yeah man he's and then he's
like it happened fast for me
and then he's like but that's all i know
so at the time i i just expect
everything to happen
fast and he said then someone called him
uh someone who owned like an improv or
something was like okay you know
saturday live's looking for a black guy
you should audition
no [ __ ] it i'll go up there gets it and
then mark was like are you just freaking
out he's like
again like i i was like the prodigy so
like yeah of course i got it
he's like at the time i realized i gotta
listen to this he's like i didn't
realize how big of a deal it is
yeah i got the job i was like yeah of
course i'm gonna i got it he's saying
i'm gonna do this i'm doing first 48 you
know
uh 48 hours yeah and i'm going to do
movies like that
like chevy chase did it before trading
places
yeah beverly hills car yeah i told you
guys i went to raw
in person i said that yeah i actually
asked you about it when when uh
when we were in phoenix but yeah so it
was amazing but you hear like kevin
hart's
i guess eddie throws a party at his
house like once a month
pre-covered like once a week and it'd be
the funnest people
that we know of in comedy like kevin
hart was everyone was there in the comic
scene
and they said they would beg eddie to do
stand-up because he was
dominate like they said he was just he's
the funniest guy in the room of course
and kevin's like dude you got to come
back and do stand up
yeah he started to do it he had all his
whole you know he's like i probably have
two hours of material
yeah and he's like but it's all notes
he's like like i haven't been able to
work it out because he was like i was
gonna go to the clubs and do it the
right way
but kovit came so now you know we'll see
you know what's crazy is i i would love
to just tell eddie
that you don't even need to uh work on
it
because when he sits you ever watch him
on a panel come on yep when he just
tells the story at the panel
like when he's on fallon or whatever
that story that gem that he says
sitting down is you got him on stage
dude you gotta listen to him on mayor
because he's just going from the hip and
it's uh
his old school story is such a beast
like something i forget who the famous
guy was
but he's saying our thing was to like uh
joke with each other like oh i bet you
won't do this
so he says he's backstage at men's
square garden with this guy forget the
guy's name famous guy
because we're backstage at a diana ross
concert and he goes eddie says to his
friend goes i bet you won't grab down or
else's ass and he's like why would you
do this to me eddie because he has to do
it
so in the middle of performance you know
he gets on stage and like what the [ __ ]
he gives her a hug and then looks at
eddie like grabs her ass
and then eddie says uh that sounded live
and it was one i forget what uh
you know that i want to rock down to
yeah
yeah yeah so these guys have dreads and
they're all in the saturday night live
they're about to perform
and uh eddie goes hey oh i guess the guy
goes
man someone told me that the way those
black guys get dreads they put goats in
their hair
and eddie goes i dare you go ask them if
they put goat [ __ ] in their hair
he's like why would you do this to me so
he walks in the room and he says he
starts off small he's like man you guys
got cool hair and though
thank you thank you and he's like yeah
it must be really difficult to get there
and they're like yeah you know it takes
some time he's like yeah uh someone told
me that you guys got to put goat [ __ ] in
your hair to get it like that
and they said it was like quiet and the
guy was like no man no
uh-uh and then he said he looked at he
goes why did you tell me that and then
that's funny he's yeah he's got a lot of
great stories yeah it's pretty new
he's a killer like he's killer like even
i watched his uh
when his uh inside actors studio james
lives
i love those dudes so good like his
especially he's just so chill and he's
gonna like he'll have a great
conversation with you
yeah and you just you just let them go
you know who is richard pryor
of course he said he met him after like
not the drug richard like when
he was going through like rehab like
when he's trying to get his life right
he said he was on a plane with him and
his album just came out and he's
and then the he was getting on the plane
the story was like uh richard price on
the plane and eddie was like oh [ __ ]
that's my hero man
so he said he had a copy on cassette of
his album went up to richard was like
can we listen us
on the plane and he was like yeah he use
i know who you are i listened to it
so he said he was like four rows back
from richard watching him
he said richard had it on was yelling
going you funny man
holy [ __ ] and then they get off the
plane
and richard's like where are you going
and he's like oh i'm going somewhere in
the hills he's like i'll give you a ride
man
and so he said he jumped in gave him a
ride there like spit game on him while
they were there
what dropped that really crazy that's an
amazing story he's got a lot of great
stories
he does all he has to do is just get up
and tell the stories man
it's like overwhelming have you ever
seen him do an impersonation it's the
best impersonator
it's so great i love jay farrell i love
jamie when they do their [ __ ]
i got it but i'm telling you when eddie
gets a hold of it it's different it is
it's
different no different it's like he
embodies it i saw him do tracy morgan
for like four seconds
and i was like did he just do that have
you seen him do his brother
charlie mommy amazing you know that's
how you got saturday night live
during the audition he just did a bunch
of impressions yeah because
charlie murphy told him to go do the
dude i can't do charlie right now
just do it though please do it hey man
we let
let molly talk you see i'm setting up
now your turn
come on just do it come on do it just do
it let's do it
charlie's watching right now you don't
have a whole lot of [ __ ] you know
charlie murphy's story he's just dying
to get out you don't watch
me wait you know the racks of riches
[Applause]
you know charlie murphy had a brother
named eddie right
what did you say hey hey did you did you
know uh
charlie murphy what him and rogan would
tour together
they put him together and charlie just
started doing stamp everyone thinks
charlie's like a stand-up he's not yeah
really late and he got famous off the
chappelle show because he would tell
stories
so they're like man you need to take
these stories and do a stand-up back
they put him and rogan together but
think about wrote especially even then
rosie's been doing con for 20 years
and rogan uh you know the the headline
the the you know the the marquee would
say joe rogan and
charlie murphy yeah well charlie murphy
sometimes closed the show out but oh
yeah
he's a monster especially back then
monster monster he's like a season comic
so rogan would tell him like dog i'm
just trying to help you out you
shouldn't
go after me he's like this just from a
comic's perspective yeah
you should go then i go man like robin's
always trying to help him out
that's dope yeah they were they were
like solid yeah that's that's really
close
that's a heavy that's a heavy thing to
put on charlie at that time
monster dude you know i mean but like i
uh i could see why the promoters
thought that you know what i mean
because at the time
at that time that was awesome remember
yeah you should go then i go exactly
that's how it should have been
those promoters have no idea yeah like
an awkward conversation but he's like
i'm literally just trying to help you
out yeah i'm just trying to show you man
that i'm about to
uh set that stage on fire and then
you're gonna go on
and you've been doing stand-up for two
minutes yeah yeah and then you're gonna
burn
yeah but that yeah sometimes that's a
that's a tough pill to swallow you know
what i mean like you know that
who you are at that time you know i mean
i deserve the spot
it's like sometimes you know you'll run
you'll come across cats that are very
humble
and and and will bow down that's why
that's why i'm so fortunate for brian
count because when i started stand up
i had training wheels because brian was
on stage with me i'd go out and do my
own [ __ ] for 10 minutes but then brian
would come out
and then i have brian who who's been in
comedy for 30 years
60 years and brian would set me up for
success
yeah you know like i'd be like oh what
are we going to do and he's like hey
remember and
you're just off to the races yeah like
brian i'll see you a tag team on oh yeah
you come out together that's great but
brian was so good at like making sure
that i didn't fail yeah he'd be like oh
hey remember that time we were doing
this i'm like oh yeah
cause he knows it's a funny story that's
the cool thing about watching brian when
i was coming up is like
you know because you know when i watched
brian it was at the clubs
so you know we were all working on our
[ __ ] you know i never went on the road
with him
so one thing i noticed with him is when
uh he tried new [ __ ]
and it would bomb he would stick with it
and just let him in
yeah commit yeah and uh and make it work
and if it didn't work you didn't give a
[ __ ] you know i mean you just go to
something else yeah and that's so that's
a hard thing to learn when you're first
coming up
you know when you start bombing right
away on some on an idea
you panic you know you freeze what do i
do next
yeah and then you have to like really
learn how to like sit down and be okay
well they were saying richard pryor like
one of the things eddie was saying
that's one thing that made him so
special
is when he was on the heroin all the
drugs he was so funny
but he's always been doing that in
stand-up so then when he got sober
eddie said whenever richard would
perform at the comedy store all the
comics
like him mooney everybody go down there
watch richard
but when he was sober he was trying to
figure it out and then marc maron was a
doorman at the time he's like dude i've
seen
richard pryor bombed like yeah for a
long time
he's like but he would stay with it he'd
stick with it stick with it stick with
it
well then eventually you'd see like six
months go by and then that [ __ ] just a
[ __ ]
it's his closing bit we said you'd eat
dick for
months yeah i wouldn't give a flying
[ __ ] that's so cool i love that i love
scary i love hearing stories like sure
guys are still i mean rogan's that you
know
brogan's the exact same way yeah i have
a concept and you'll see him in the main
room you know he closes out
we're all going before we have our bits
from the road that we know are going to
hit yeah we'll go on there
he has all his notes he records it he'll
go out there
it might not work those first few weeks
and you're like god damn
bombing out there and that is excuse me
and then next thing you know a few
months go by and he's just a [ __ ]
killer with that
i love it oh your boy george um he he
what that was his first that was his
first time ever on stage yeah yeah
he was an officer that's the youtuber
guy with logan paul yeah yeah it was
just it was cool to
you know i offered that up to him i
don't like to tell people you know what
i mean because i
because he's got a huge following yeah
so my whole thing with that is uh
and i've done it before for other people
as well but i'm like if you're trying to
get into this game
like do it the do it the right way learn
the craft man don't let anyone know
you're growing up don't tell your fans
you're going up no yeah because the
minute they start paying for tickets to
come see you
yeah they're never coming back yeah so i
told him that i go look dude my shows
are already
done we don't have to worry about ticket
sales just walk up no one's got to know
you're here
don't announce that you're there yeah
yeah yeah and and have an honest crowd
in front of you
yeah that way you because if you're
going to do it right they're going to
laugh at you saying hi
how much time did you give them like man
it started with five and then it went to
nine and then it went to like 15.
it was good but he yeah he like uh he
just appreciated
yeah which is like you know some people
like i feel like they when they get into
it they're like yeah i do stand-up
comedy but like
he really wanted to like be good up
there
yeah you know what i mean yeah he would
appreciate it yeah you can always ask
questions
yeah always ask questions all that like
you [ __ ] hope so
yeah like yeah he better be that
like a lot of guys getting this game and
comments right away
and they you we are not the same yeah
we're not the same so much [ __ ] to work
on dude yeah a lot of people told me i
used to take guys on the road right
i would get like 14 sold out shows at
the san jose improv right and i have an
opener for
come with me right and uh there's a guy
i always take the same guy
on the road right and then uh and then
at the end of the week
a tweet would go like hey man thank you
all for coming out to see me
like what it'll be a picture a picture
of him at the end probably
him no [ __ ] you're thinking
yeah yeah yeah like all up in the videos
he's like fourteen
sold out yeah hey you guys let's make it
15 next year
[Laughter]
we gotta
[Laughter]
yeah that was the thing about george man
he just appreciated this yeah
how's he going since huh has he been on
oh yeah he goes up but like i keep
telling him
don't tell people you're on the oh she
announced it no no he doesn't he he
that's the thing he listens he just
listen i i don't know the guy yeah
really nice guy man yeah this dude right
here man he's he's fun to told you yeah
he's fun to watch
goes up and does how about he's selling
out his own shows now yeah
he sold out kansas city improv sold out
austin that's amazing which we're going
back there
yeah yeah april 22nd tickets to be on
sale probably in the next few days but
vulkan was it volcano
gas company i got six shows there uh
april 22 to 24th
that's sick feels good go back to
phoenix your hometown
yeah let's go bro let's go that's him
shadow box yeah
malik will be at 7 11. i'll be on the
stage
you know the next rave yeah
it was so funny it was so funny because
i kept texting uh chappelle like yo you
here
he's like yeah i'm here i'm in the hotel
i'm like good right yeah and i come up
the elevator and i go down the hallway
and i see chappelle
standing in the hallway with his
suitcase talking to
someone in the door like i'm like this
motherfucker's already talking to people
you know like like how social is this
[ __ ] guy right
and then i get close to the door and
it's malik just
just a boxer shorts in his gold chain in
his watch yeah man what time's the show
started
i wanted to learn i never boxer shorts
gold chain in his watch i just got him i
like how you call it his watch
he doesn't even give you the credit what
the heck
did you open up for somebody like that
um
my favorite uh beast to open for
was cedric i always say this story
i always tell this story i say it all
the time it was uh
man let's let's i think my son was a
year old so then that was 16 years ago
and chappelle when i opened for
chappelle was uh
25 years ago and that was an amazing
thing like i was just like five years in
the game and here i am opening for him
at the house of blues
sold out and then here comes where
mandalay bay
oh wow and here comes dave walking in in
a suit and i'm just sitting there i
still smell like dolphin [ __ ] you know
because i'm a tour guide
and uh and he just said sounds like hey
man like what's your name and he
introduced myself and then uh he goes uh
oh because i used to open for these
headliners and they would get mad at
certain bits i would do
and then i told him i go hey i do like
these kind of this bit and that bit
and i go and a lot of headliners get mad
and he goes really
they get mad i go yeah he goes but then
they're not headliners
oh yeah he'd be correct that's five
years in like
in the into my career you hear that yeah
and you know i was just like
happy i was opening for people and like
every time i headlined like hey man you
might want to stop doing that bit
and do that you know because i was like
and i would listen i'm like
okay yeah my bad just you know whatever
you want me to do i was just happy to
get on stage
then i told dave because i didn't want
to [ __ ] this opportunity up yeah i just
thought that's how headliners act
and then he was like really they're not
headlining that's hilarious
the headliner should be able to see
whoever's in front of them and then have
another
four or five hours to cover whatever it
is that they talked about like if you
cross
yeah you cross the same premise yeah i
still got two more hours some other [ __ ]
that they didn't talk about christ
yes that's a headliner and i swear to
god that was always my mentality after
that
yep i've always had that mentality with
him like i don't give a [ __ ] what you do
in front of me yeah
and then uh and then cedric is uh
i opened for him at the pochenga you
know it's like a big
yeah is that that's like down by i don't
know where it's
like 3 thousand people i tell this story
all the time because it was like it was
like
it was like an awe moment you know what
i mean because this is when i was like
i was doing closer close and close to
close to close up like my whole routine
opening for people was just like
15 minutes of just applause break you
know i was just going for the jugular
you know what i mean
and with the whole like in my head i'm
like there's no way
anyone's following this [ __ ] like that
that was always my attitude right yeah
and i said good night they're screaming
i look to my left in my head i'm like
there ain't no way cedric's going to
fall this [ __ ]
but chang is going to hire me after this
[ __ ] right that's my [ __ ] yeah
and i look to my left and cedric is just
in this
[ __ ] outfit bro so same matching
fedora with the the
the jacket with the the vest clean the
matching tie
ostrich yeah you know and then he's
bouncing like this he's like that's what
i'm talking about [ __ ]
for that money [ __ ]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the entertainer and
i'm just standing on the side
as he walks out and literally like maybe
a minute into his act
i'm like these [ __ ] have
already forgotten
it was over man his intro was [ __ ]
you know that yeah because the intro was
fire
stopped it never stops i think that's
always been my mentality when i have
people open for me i'm like yo kill it
bring it
yeah yeah that's different [ __ ] waves
exactly what you said to me yeah
kill it kill it go out there and i was
doing all new [ __ ] all off the top of my
head i was like yo i'm
like freestyling yeah he rolled out
there every night he's not
right he had nothing new [ __ ] nothing
hour and a half and i'm just like
professional man i mean he's one of the
top 20 comments
i think it's weird too like we were just
in tampa
chappelle didn't come but malik and i
were in tampa and i have
guys my first friends i'm in comedy
outside la are in tan are in
florida miami nice ricky cruz and
luis uh what's his last name luis or
something
louis yeah thank you man yeah are you
just all
enjoyed yes luis diaz lewis christ
louise something was like thank you man
thank you
[Applause]
and uh after the weekend both are like
man thanks for being so nice to us and
i'm like who the [ __ ] is that nice yeah
dude we there's some people we open up
for they wouldn't let us in the green
room
and we can't even talk to them what is
it like like we just hang outside of the
green room i'm like who the [ __ ]
they told me the guy's names i'm not to
say them but like you can't
yeah they're like i can't even we can't
my conversation
and he was the one guy was one of my
heroes and i was like yeah so i won't
talk to him is it cool if i get a
picture afterwards and the manager's
like no
he wants nothing to do with you like
just do your job
get out it's like what the [ __ ] wrong
with these people i don't understand
that dude i don't get it either
it's one of the greatest things is
talking to the comments no [ __ ] talking
about the road and
enjoying that moment yeah all the laughs
you're not even in the moment
yeah you're not even in the moment if
you're doing that you're literally just
doing it as
as if you're clocking in at a at a
regular job
like you'll meet them in miami they're
they're okay monsters yeah
that's crazy not weird yeah i don't like
hearing stories like that
i've met a couple comics some of my
heroes i've heard
stories like that though where they're
just straight up like yeah you can't
come in
even joe let me in the green room i
didn't want to yeah
phoenix the watch got you in though
[Laughter]
i was in there okay i got it
thank you to our sponsors
we got these shirts rags man
cheesecake it's the brand baby it's like
starting out with the jameson joe you
know what to do with your feet
he's got slogans it's not a brand it's a
vibe
what the [ __ ] did you just say bro what
the [ __ ] did malek just say
he goes out of here it's not even
anything
man you guys know me it ain't a brand
it's a god
get your merch i went from pushing mobs
to owning mom
good night like he ended every show like
that
we love you baby we love you
all right what do you got first catcher
oh [ __ ] okay
so a 41 year old man who is currently
unemployed
with a law degree from oxford is suing
his parents
saying that they are leaving him as a
vulnerable adult
child that because they took care of him
for his entire life he shouldn't now
be uh he shouldn't be an adult and
basically provide for himself
a special kind of [ __ ] to sue your
parents for
for loving you so much where you're
scared of the world yeah
that you have to make a life for
yourself every single week he has been
uh receiving 400 euros as an allowance
from his parents around 700
yeah plus seven hundred eight hundred
bucks yeah you you [ __ ]
every single [ __ ] yeah right one year
old man
with a law degree from oxford yeah you
didn't pay for it
your parents paid for that don't use
your degree you piece of [ __ ]
and when he went to oxford his parents
actually rented him
a one million dollar flat for him to
stay
oh they're rich so he's just like
money they got that oil money wait are
you talking about dubai money the same
people that bought
i think they may be distant relatives
okay
so you mean japanese yeah and for our
audience listeners you said flat that's
like condo in uh english yes
i really really hate you i
hate you so so much we go two steps
forward then yeah seven back
yeah yeah for those of you who don't
know what a flat is yeah yeah
well listeners yeah for our listeners
pandemic
yeah last year 2020. there was this
disease
yeah it started at 7 11. in dubai
god damn it i hate this guy
i hate him oh i'm talking about him if
you look at his picture if you look at
his picture
he does look like a big big [ __ ] he
looks like he's blind
chapstick he looks like he breast fed
until he was
22. obviously he doesn't have friends
because if you're around with your
friends like drinking whatever you're
like yeah i'm about to sue my parents
like
what yeah for what because man they're
not taking care of me i'm like you're
40. one dude don't you have a law degree
right he probably ain't got no friends
though no
no the the chat room's his friends and
they're all like yeah
sue them zoom in and then take care of
your mother
yeah and they just they did you
exaggerate
[ __ ] my parents yeah you're right dude
they did you wrong man
it's putting you up
degree from oxford you'll be a [ __ ]
beast man yeah i'm saying that he's not
getting enough from his parents
currently to maintain his lifestyle
and that's what he's like so he's a
lawyer he's not a lawyer he has a law
degree he doesn't necessarily mean that
he took
yeah he took the bar or that he's a
practice yeah there's no way he's going
to win that
i mean let's jump i hope not i hope not
can you imagine if the court
grants him money from yeah there's no
way we're like what
leg does he have to stand on i have no
idea i mean you know
yeah he is a lawyer so he might know
something
also i don't know if he actually first
lord if he actually like
tr studied in school bless you it seems
like he has
parents who like got them just now
speaking of pandemic yeah
your two-week lockdown is now extended
yeah
yeah don't don't let [ __ ] steven
spielberg see this
[ __ ] man i love you joe
okay piers morgan went hard on meghan
markle for
the uh oprah interview he always has
though this is so yeah
you know he's always gone hard at meghan
markle and uh homeboy
yeah and prince harry yeah um but when
the interview came out he went on
hard on them again and he said that he
doesn't believe anything that meghan
markle says
and a lot of people don't though yeah
that's fair uh but a lot of people
didn't like that when he was talking
about
her being a liar that it also he was
speaking about it at the same time he
was speaking about her talking about
being suicidal and so a lot of people
thought he was being very insensitive
one of his co-anchors on the show
actually called him out on it
yeah he stormed off of the show said he
didn't want to sit down for the rest of
the
here's the thing i need to storm off
your show yeah
his show he's like i don't need to put
up i'm out of here
it's your show man yeah yeah you left
the weather man there production's like
yeah okay can you play this jin yeah
he then actually quit right after he
left the show permanently
oh [ __ ] he's over really he's always
defend the royal family
always yeah they might be paying him who
knows i like piers morgan he had an
overwhelming amount
of negative okay i'm done with this no
no no no no no sorry no
do you know what that's probably good
maybe not mine no no no no no no no no
no i'm being
sorry absolutely which is weird because
morgan's a beast yeah like why is that
when someone calls you out why do you
walk off incredibly hard
wow dude but i mean he why would he walk
off drop they gotta drop some like
pretty
something else yeah you know it's hard
not to agree with this it's hard because
if that's
like whether she you know some one of
her friends came out said she's a
complete sociopath and like she's full
of [ __ ] yeah
we don't know but she's like hey man i'm
suicidal because
you know the the press in the uk like
the sun and [ __ ] they're
rough man everybody they're [ __ ]
rough they're the ones that make auntie
joshua's like i'm going to africa
yeah those are pieces of [ __ ] yeah but
you you saw the interview with
uh pierce when he said that he had a
thing with her they had an actual
relationship
and then she left i guess they were on a
date i'm not i don't know
the facts but they were on like a date
kind of and she left went to a party and
that's when she met prince harry
and never talked to him again oh and
then he said
and then he said it really broke my
heart i really liked her so that's
it this is more of a this is a
brilliant yeah this is a personal
character morgan's be
i'm a fan of pizza morgan i'm not a fan
of this i don't agree with him at all
this yeah
i like piers morgan in general okay i
usually tend to agree with him i love
when he's on cnn
you know he took over for larry king got
a lot of [ __ ] but did his thing i think
he's a great interviewer
but this what happened super
unprofessional he took his personal life
and then brought it into his job and now
he's hating on her at any point he can
get
yeah and then the media does not protect
their
celebrities in any fashion yeah they
really go out and this guy did it
cleanly too like it was like a
literal it was literally like a like an
art legit yeah
very articulate and it was just like yo
i'm dropping facts and if your peers
morgan why won't you sit in the cutting
like dude this is why i did this yeah
but he was like i'm out of here all our
boy did was just hold the mirror up and
oh boy just left
here what what's crazy is he's he gives
he gives it harder than that that's
what's weird appears more you know he
hears people harder that guy was being
logical
that guy was just like breaking down
logic didn't paris morgan like send a
tweet about larry king
and uh because well larry king hated
people yeah exactly
yeah that's we got relief from his
duties at cnn and paris filled in
okay so they didn't like each other they
had been yeah yeah he passed away
i like i actually like piers morgan but
i don't agree with him and any faster
than this dude
i don't think she went with prince harry
and not you yeah now you're gonna paint
this
horrible picture of her yeah and here's
what's not to believe like there's a lot
of people not believing
um you know how hard it if i was prince
if i was a prince
right i'm second in line to be king you
know you already know that
uh what's his name his brother his
brother is what prince what uh
prince andrew or what is his name
william prince william we all know
princess
william's gonna be king we all know that
right but you're prince harry
you're second in command you're you're
next in line to be king if something
happens to william
and you're walking away from it it must
be bad
it has to be bad you guys are walking
away
in a 22 million dollar match in
montecito but you're taking it easy
but you're still walking away from
royalty but did you hear what harry said
he goes you know until i met uh maybe
markle
like i didn't real like like my brother
and my dad can't leave and i feel bad
for him they're trapped yeah he's like
and i thought i was trapped too i met
meghan markle
now we decided to get out like i don't
want to be us be involved with that good
yeah good meal who gives here's my thing
who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah if he's happy
and she's happy yeah what the [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ]
yeah and you know what's crazy it's
2020.
wow man you guys have no political
anything they don't do anything they
don't do anything
nothing if there's a warrior king
doesn't go let's
fight [ __ ] get back in your
the house family is our version of the
kardashians that you're so right that's
all they are you're so right because
the only elizabeth you're kris
kardashian yeah
that's it like that's all you do no but
but literally
they're famous they they pay taxes for
the royal family like
it's literally paid for them to
represent
what they look like it's it's a paid
image they have nothing to do with
anything man
she doesn't make any rules like nothing
yeah they just exist she's just the
richest so it's just tradition
yeah they're just holding on to it it's
a very old old tradition which
i dig you know i i like that yeah but
it's also 21 yeah
they do they do possess a lot of wealth
but well
some say she's the richest person on
earth yeah oh yeah yeah just her crown
alone they were talking about the jewels
how much those are but the royal
jewels yeah it's crazy but but they have
no
political power
the queen can't wake up and go taxes are
raised today like
no no no no so it's like so yeah they're
paid to represent
because it's like the kardashians it's
our version of the cardinals
yeah our kardashians are the same thing
same [ __ ]
that's so funny man
so a millionaire is currently suing his
ex-girlfriend because he says that he
was tricked
into a relationship with her and funding
her only fans account
because when they met he said that um he
was under the understanding that she was
a fashion model not necessarily like an
instagram only fans model
and so he would try to woo her with what
he says a million dollars worth of gifts
and luxuries takes her on par
to parties expensive vacations and what
she would do
is take naked photos of herself on these
vacations
like in his home and post it on her only
fans he's saying that he didn't know
this and now he's suing her for damages
oh okay hey bro you're a liar yeah yeah
you're a liar bro
what do you mean you didn't know you
know that's the dude right there yeah
yeah you already know what's up bro come
on and her lawyers have come out and
said that it's because
she broke up with him and he won't let
her salty
yeah yeah i don't trust guys like that
they'll have to
shoot the suit on top gene on the bottom
guys
because i'm still you know unless you're
jerry seinfeld yeah elizabeth jerry
seinfeld but other than that
this guy's trying real hard you know
what i mean he he really thinks deep in
his head
yeah that uh 20 20 year old girls love
this outfit
he has the beads on he's like yeah yeah
yeah dude i thought he was doing it i
had no idea she did that with my
with only fans i had no idea yeah nice
handkerchief stop it bro
nice what handkerchief
came to a screeching halt yeah there's
always there's always roadblocks and
that roadblock
is malik it's we're just talking
so there's a tick tock that went viral
it's about gen z millennials wanting to
cancel
eminem because of a lyric that he wrote
like you know years and years ago with
rihanna i won't stop even
when my hair turns gray i'm tone deaf
that's an old song that he did before
that he really put out again after this
article or the tick tock came out
and then uh let me let me just actually
play this clip for you
because it was trending on twitter and
uh oh this
right here
one but then everyone's coming to his
defense they're they're really serious
with this they went to castle
they said it could possibly be a joke
but they were taking it seriously no
they're
they're these [ __ ] kids man go [ __ ]
yourself yeah go [ __ ] yourself
big time like what point do you think
art
is uh actual reality yeah
do you really think he wants to set
someone on fire or is he telling a story
through song it's like he that
like he's a rapper but one thing i love
about him is he tells this story
it's a story it's a very [ __ ] up story
that's the song stands
it's a great story it's not reality yeah
like wait are we gonna go through all
old school rap lyrics and cancel them
off of that let's cancel [ __ ] it oh
my god no that's a wrap yeah facebook
like they're all screwed stupid stop
nothing [ __ ] stop pandemic dude
they're locked down what they're
irritable they have no money
what what happens is you you uh
uh desensitize when you keep
wanting to cancel every everything and
then when it comes time to cancel
something that's real yeah then it's all
gonna be like laughable no what do you
think it's not laughable it's it's just
so a lot of artists are coming to
eminem's defense including corey taylor
from slit knot
and this is a little nausea i'll just
play the clip yeah used to play for a
slipknot right
wants to cancel eminem
generation z wants to cancel eminem
oh
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] that was crazy
but i'll take it yeah but it is i mean
it's just it's so stupid it's ridiculous
again like why we need to open up we
need to open up people are bored yeah
but it's like okay cancel and then what
do you think we're doing i can't wha do
you mean cancel it's like whatever
it's like morgan wallin made a real
mistake using the n-word
around his friend who was drunk do you
know what happened to morgan wallin he
got castle
oh papa no no number one no not taking
sales because
pandemic but because on itunes has
the top eight number one songs in the
country and the top
all his albums are number one too
because people are sick of this [ __ ] man
just because morgan wallin granted he
shouldn't use that word he's not racist
he [ __ ] up made a mistake but people
want to cancel them so
the culture people are striking back
like no no no so you can take them off
radio that doesn't mean you're canceled
the the public decides if you're
canceled and i guarantee the public's
not canceled m
m oh yeah well i can't say morgan wallin
not kenton
it's just it doesn't work that way no he
was going to say something before
i just was going to tell you to stop
talking
oh [ __ ] i know are you loud and clear
meanwhile poor chin's trying not to [ __ ]
his pants in this entire show
not [ __ ] my pants food was it dairy
i don't know what it was i had the same
food as them
because dairy [ __ ] me up well asians
yeah it's harry you give me ice cream
and i love ice cream but i know man
i know going in while i'm eating it i'm
like this is about to be a real bad day
a really bad day you don't take a
lactate pill no no
everywhere yeah did that make sense
what's this uh so everyone knows that
lady gaga her
dog napper uh they try to well they
actually shot her
dog walker and apparently that was more
of a king they think it's a gang
initiation not an actual
them trying to take the dog wait what
yeah they still took the dogs they did
but that's they're saying like they're
not even sure why they took them but
they could have easily left the dogs
there uh i feel like this is two white
cops being like i know what's happening
here
they can't figure it out they're like
you think they're driving through
beverly hills and shooting
dog walkers as a gang nation like the
only thing that makes sense man
that's i mean like it wouldn't have been
a struggle for them to take dogs so
it was weird but um also they're saying
that uh the woman that found him
they're lady gaga wants to give her the
500 000 reward
but they want to make sure 100 percent
that you know she's involved with yeah
completely
oh yeah and they'll figure that out too
by the way oh yeah they'll figure it out
we've all seen way too much catch
first four yeah i love that show god is
so good
always in oklahoma in miami yeah and you
know what i always solve it i always
solve it in the first three hours
you do i don't know why we're going to
commercial
figured it out already yeah right he did
it
i love when they confess because they
like they always confess when they hit
their shirt their arms in their shirt
you want to tell me a little poo i get a
cigarette
and then the cops are all friendly they
leave them there for like six hours yeah
then
i'm ready i want to talk to somebody
then the first thing can i get a
cigarette the cop's like sure buddy
so are you ready to tell the truth yeah
yeah we already know
that's what they always say we we know
he didn't mean to do it the gun went off
in his face
yeah yeah let us help you just tell us
what you're doing
mixed plate nice can't wait to read this
it's on
amazon you get it at target so you can
get at barnes and
that's dealt though the book comes out
march 23rd
uh march 23rd oh yeah i did an audio too
man that's [ __ ]
if you get your book brennan chappelle
mm-hmm
i'm telling you i'm telling you right
now
if you thought you could read yeah you
can't
i've heard you write it is
the worst gig of your life is
reading your own [ __ ] and
it it's hard bro it was hard and one the
book is very emotional so
like you know there were some stories i
wish i you know like i know i'm glad i
told them but it was it was hard to read
like i told you like when they go hey
you want to do the audio version i was
like yeah i was all
but i didn't know i was going to take
that kind of emotion you know but
damn just you've got to hit everyone all
that yeah you can download it right now
oh no no no you can't get it yet yeah
just get booked i said good book right
there oh yeah you can get it
no it's a it's you i think it's
pre-order right yeah pre-order yeah
ain't that a [ __ ] i love it come on
proud of you dude thank you awesome i
love your story you're killing it man
yeah i appreciate it mm-hmm there it is
look at that
signed okay all right that's crazy oh
wait
i brought it oh [ __ ] oh you brought us
some copies of it
are you serious i only have one copy oh
i'm gonna go ahead and read that on the
plane
sorry it's a loaf oh okay is that in
front of the ford
look at me you sold out a variety
slot out two shows
oh here it is i'm gonna have to take
that fellas yeah i'll read it first
you pass it around you get to me no i'm
gonna send you guys copies oh oh
oh oh i'll send you this one that's the
original and my son signed this one for
me oh
okay i won't take your signs oh damn
that's cool that's hard
so that's the form right yeah that's so
cool man
thank you bro that's so dope thank you
thank you well i wish you would have
given us a book i know we were all
excited i was excited
i was going to read it we were all ready
for it i was like damn books
you're like does that [ __ ] look tight
all right guys we'll see all right
because he said he probably looks like
he has goodies
he gets good i'm sorry oh you're good
good man
go get his book man pre-order it right
now barnes noble
uh amazon all over uh yeah apple books
everywhere ladies thank you jokoy mix
plate
we love you man i love you guys thank
you we are off to cleveland they're only
tickets left are thursday
friday both shows are sold out saturday
both shows are sold out
so get tickets there's 20 tickets left
for the thursday show
at hilarity's in cleveland and then
spokane washington
we added shows thursday there's a late
show now in early saturday
march 18th through the 20th is that the
spokane comedy club yeah
oh it's so good i haven't done that one
oh you're gonna love it that's great
yeah
miami florida march 25th through the
27th and then coming up soon
april 22nd through the 24th austin texas
baby let's go
f-a-t-k-z for tickets that's it man
love you guys boy we love you man go get
his book where else
oh um malik b i got the off-white press
ropes
green laces
[Music]
yeah pool full of liquor then you dive
in you know what i'm saying
kung fu kenny you know what i'm saying
better back homie
i got loyalty royalty inside my dna
though
you know what i did [ __ ]
what brandon got today joe coy's
freaking coffee get some his books out
so make sure you get
that these will be going to cleveland so
get your mind right cleveland
that's what it is i'm going to eat now